Victim impact evidence.
One of the more controversial areas of
capital punishment at the penalty phase
of a capital trial.
The prosecution can in most states,
put on evidence from the victim's family
or members of the community to talk
about what the impact on
the community has been.
And on the survivors,
the supreme court first said in booth
versus Maryland that this evidence was not
admissible,
but just a short time later after a change
in some members of the court held in
Payne versus Tennessee,
that such evidence was admissible.
And now in almost all the states
that have the death penalty,
victim impact evidence is admissible.
I've asked five students from Yale law
school to come here and discuss the
various aspects of victim impact evidence,
uh,
with us today.
I want to introduce Megan walked
suppressed who is from Chicago,
who's with us as well as
Emma Kaufman from Carlisle,
Pennsylvania to my immediate
right is Jamil Giovanni from,
uh,
Toronto,
to my left if familiar,
Morgan from Los Angeles.
Uh,
and finally Virginia,
uh,
mccline bit who was from Iowa.
So,
uh,
I want to thank all of them,
for joining us here today
to talk about this subject.
And Jamil,
let me just start with you.
What is,
what,
what is the victim impact evidence?
What does the jury do with it?
Well,
the jury's going to use that information
to sort of get the full picture of the,
the harm caused by the
crime in particular,
the impact on the family,
whether it's financial,
emotional,
psychological,
um,
trying to get a larger picture of
what happened as a result of the crime
committed by the defendant.
And
what does the dream do with that?
I mean,
how does it weigh it?
It's deciding it's got
aggravating circumstances,
mitigating circumstances.
What is,
so what does it do with it?
I mean,
I think theoretically it goes to the
jury's understanding of the victim who was
lost and the extent of the harm committed.
So it gives the jury a better sense
of who it was that was affected by the
crime,
which goes to the gravity of the crime.
Megan,
do you have any different,
well,
I think it also serves a purpose
within the courtroom for the victims
themselves.
I mean it's introduced after the Mig or
alongside the mitigating evidence stage
in which you get a much fuller picture
of the defendant's life and why they're
deserving of the jury sympathy.
And so it feels like a
way of counteracting that
vision of the defendant in
defense of the perceived harm by the
victim and the victim's family shooting
part of why this evidence is admissible,
the balance out,
the mitigating evidence
about the defendant with
the seven and it's about the
person whose life was taken.
Um,
I mean I think that's theoretically
one of the rationales for it,
again,
to get a full,
a full picture of the crime.
Um,
I think a lot of people would say
that that is prejudicial that in,
um,
in the penalty phase looking at
the defendant and it's about that person
and their life and so extra information
about the,
uh,
the victim just serves to confuse
what's happening in the courtroom.
Collaborate on that just a little bit.
Are you saying maybe the seven
it should be admitted or,
or it should be.
One of the questions we have of course
is not only if it's going to be admitted,
which the Supreme Court
has pretty much decided,
but the scope of the
evidence once it comes in,
how much,
how much evidence is going to be allowed.
Right?
Yeah.
I think,
I think you have to be very careful
about how the evidence is presented.
And so,
um,
because it can have extraordinarily
prejudicial effects for the defendant.
And I think that,
um,
often,
I mean,
when you're looking at a capital case,
you're always going to be
dealing with someone who's,
who's died.
Like there's always going
to be someone who's Dad.
And so,
um,
that's obviously hugely
harmful for the community.
But when you,
when you bring in all of
these people who aren't,
who are talking about their loss,
there's a risk that the defendant
isn't going to get a fair trial.
Do you remember what are,
what are your thoughts about this in
terms of it is a fair trial risk by this
cause this evidence be too emotional or,
uh,
what,
what's your take on it?
Yeah,
absolutely.
I think there's a,
there's a risk at hand here when you
have people kind of pulling at the
heartstrings of a jury.
Uh,
they might make decisions that are more
motivated by emotional appeal as opposed
to fairness or as opposed to what is the
kind of reasonable application of the
law.
Uh,
but ultimately,
uh,
I think there's the,
the,
the important thing is the restorative
aspect that I think it can give to
victims and making sure they
get to play a part in the,
in the,
in the trial and making sure that their,
their,
uh,
their experience through the crime is
being weighed by people and that they are
some fairness to their process
and some closure for them as well
before we're done to scope.
I mean,
is there anybody that thinks this evidence
just shouldn't be admitted that the
court got it wrong and,
and,
and Payne versus Tennessee?
Emma?
Yeah.
I think it's,
I think justice Stevens wrote in his
dissent to the opinion that allowed it in
that we're just entering
unchartered sees of irrelevance.
I think that was how he put it.
My impression is that what you're
supposed to be thinking about during the
penalty phase of a capital trial is the
defendant's crime and whether or not the
defendant's life has mitigating
aspects to the sentence,
right.
So I just think we're going beyond the
scope entirely of what is at issue in the
penalty phase,
Megan.
Well,
I think that there's a,
there's a real risk that it sets the jury
up to believe that the only way to do
proper or to properly honor
the life of the victim and,
and to show respect for the victim is to
give the death penalty when that those
two,
whether or not to choose death for the
defendant and whether or not one honors
and appreciates the loss of the victim
seem to be two different determinations
that get conflated or confused by the
admission of victim impact statements and
evidence.
Let's spend just a moment.
I'm talking about the scope,
uh,
of this evidence.
Some courts have allowed just very
brief statements being made by,
uh,
witnesses about the person,
who's no longer in large
to the victim of the crime.
Uh,
others have allowed a very elaborate
even characterizations of the crime,
the family talking about what punishment
they want imposed a in the materials we
cite to justice Stevens,
a descending opinion.
And in one case in which
you put a videotape,
uh,
on the website,
with regard to a 20 minute videotape,
a about a person,
is there any limit to,
is there any limit to this evidence?
Well,
I think that's part of the problem that
was wrong with sort of the pain decision
in general.
The court didn't really set any
standards or guidance for courts to um,
applying,
deciding what should be
the scope of this evidence.
And so now you have cases
where there's video tapes,
maybe 40 minutes long,
extremely long composition by Enya or
something along those lines where it's,
the evidence is extremely
emotionally evocative.
And so there's really an issue I would
say with scope and the courts haven't
really across the board I'm found a
sufficient way of sort of challenging this
type of evidence and ensuring that
there's not disparities between courtrooms
and defendants given the quality of the
victim impact evidence that's presented.
And certainly January she stayed too
taking different approaches.
I mean some states like Oklahoma is
allowed all sorts of evidence to come in,
whereas Georgia requires a hearing before
where the witnesses testify and only
very limited presentations.
Right.
And I think,
I think that again gets
to the problem with,
um,
the death penalty being arbitrary and
capricious as administered in different
states.
That if you are going to
allow this kind of evidence,
and I think it has to be,
um,
pretty severely constrained in
terms of what you can offer.
Um,
and I think it's,
it's just really difficult
because as Megan said,
it's,
um,
you know,
it's,
it's something for the victim and their
family to be able to express the grief
at the loss.
And,
um,
but that's really not,
and that's,
that's something that needs to happen.
It's just not clear to me that where
that needs to happen is that the penalty
phase of a capital trial when the issue
was really the individual defendant and
their individual sentence and they're
being prosecuted by the state for what
they did that was contrary
to the laws of the state.
And so it's hard because I think you
have to draw a pretty fine distinction
between what the purpose of the penalty
phases and even though part of it is
honoring the loss of the
victim and their family,
that's,
that's really not the main purpose,
Chris,
to the quality of this evidence is
going to vary some depending upon how
articulate the members of the victim's
family or you may have people from a
prominent family may have
someone who has no family at all.
So there's no one to testify.
Uh,
Justice Betterman the Georgia
Supreme Court Express some concern,
uh,
about,
two classes of victims are,
are we concerned about that journal?
Uh,
well I think we're concerned about that.
And so far as there are inequalities and
disparities in American society and so
you're going to have
different levels of education,
diff,
how different degrees in which people
can be eloquent and articulate their
experience through a crime and the impact
is left on them and their families.
I don't think that a trial is where
we necessarily need to be concerned,
uh,
about trying to equalize this.
People are going to,
we are being,
we're essentially asking us are we going
to make a qualitative decision about
how well we think someone communicates,
articulates.
And I don't think that's
really the goal here.
The goal is to create an opportunity for
people who have been affected to speak
about how they've been affected.
I think there's a great point I believe
made by Justice Scalia where he talks
about how there's going to be
differences between one defense attorney,
another.
There's going to be different
than the one prosecutor and other,
there's always going to be
these qualitative differences
in how well someone can
be articulate and how all
they can be an advocate.
And I think that,
um,
you know,
we should,
that's a natural part of the,
the legal system and uh,
we,
I don't think being too preoccupied
with that is really the,
the point here that every victim is
going to come from a different angle with
different things to say and we need
to respect and honor that can come in
different forms.
So say this is just the vagaries
of the system in any crime,
it may be that the witnesses or
articulate or not witnesses to testify the
lawyers may be a of different
quality and so forth,
comfortable with those
kinds of inequalities that I
think that's a conversation
we need to be having our
school large and our,
yeah,
and our larger social issues and not,
not when it comes to a trial,
Emma,
I mean I agree with Jamil that we need
to be having a broader conversation about
embedded inequalities.
But it seems to me that if the goal
in sentencing is to determine what's
appropriate for the crime that was done,
that there's something wrong with a
hierarchy of victim hood in which those
people who know more people
who are more eloquent,
who are more well connected,
are going to have more of an emotional
impact on a jury than those people who
aren't.
Right.
Ultimately,
the impression you're giving is that
murdering someone who is more prominent in
society is more problematic
or more offensive than
murdering someone who doesn't
have family members to come
testify on their behalf.
Anyone else want to comment on that,
Megan?
Oh,
well I think that there's some worry,
some intersections with,
for example,
the results in McCleskey v
Camp of the empirical study of,
of when the death penalty is granted.
And so you,
right,
and in that case you're talking about,
just so everybody knows
what we're talking about,
the case racial discrimination and
the racial disparities and the Dustin,
right.
So,
yeah,
so through very extensive empirical work,
they found that the way to increase
the likelihood of receiving the death
penalty is basically to be an African
American individual whom earners a white
individual and,
and the way in which that the kinds of
effects of what lives are considered
valuable and what lives are considered
the death of which people is considered a
particularly heinous crime.
I think given the broader structural
problems our society has intersect with
real in really uncomfortable
ways with a face frame,
uh,
phase of the trial devoted to
measuring the severity of that impact.
Well,
back to my earlier question
about the scope of this.
What,
what should the scope be?
I mean,
should we allow,
uh,
extensive testimony with these
video tapes and so forth or,
or,
or is there a principle way to
decide how much evidence to allow?
I think that's a very difficult question.
I don't think that there have been many
courts that have really addressed that
head on.
But I do think that I agree somewhat
with the purse a bar as relates to the
victim impact videos.
I think it's very hard to sort of
standardize the quality of victim,
um,
videos as technology advances,
as there's differences in resources.
Um,
and I also think that the,
uh,
approach adopted by the
Georgia Supreme Court,
I believe,
um,
to go through written testimonies and
allow victims to present their testimony
through a written statement,
but then go through an excise those
parts that are maybe very prejudicial
towards a defendant
referring to the defendant,
let's say in a disparaging way.
Keeping the focus on impact
might be one way of channeling,
um,
the evidence that's presented to the
court and trying to keep away a testimony
that might unduly inflame the jury.
So I do believe that
statement should play a role.
Um,
but victim impact videos,
I don't think that there's a,
a principled way of channeling those
types of videos and perhaps outside of
maybe a hard time limit,
but then you still couldn't
really control the quality.
Um,
so I would say that's
probably one approach
for any of those videos are,
are,
are quite often admitted and
are pretty much standard,
uh,
practice,
in that state.
The Supreme Court really has been
looked at this since the time of pain,
which in which the,
at least just so Connor said,
this was a brief glimpse
at the victim's life,
but at least we see in some states now,
it's a much more elaborate
a glimpse than just a,
a brief claps.
Jenny.
Yeah,
I really agree with what Julia said,
that it's,
um,
I think to the extent that
you're going to allow it,
it has to be fairly
circumscribed and controlled.
Um,
and I think the court should know in
advance what's going to be stuck said.
And essentially the only way to do
that is through a written statement.
I think that again,
these victims and their families have
had hugely traumatic experiences and I
just,
it's um,
if you,
if you got into a situation where
someone said something that was the court
eventually said was more prejudicial
than probative or whatever,
it's just,
it's very hard for,
um,
it's very easy for just one
comment to tape taint the whole,
the whole trial or the
whole penalty phase.
And so,
um,
definitely I think the videos
are really problematic,
especially with,
you know,
the soft music in the
background and it's just,
it's really,
I mean,
these are very moving
things and they should be,
it's just,
I don't think that they
belong in the courtroom
in,
in one of the cases it's in the
materials George Battles case,
uh,
the prison guards,
this was a fellow who was accused and
convicted of killing a prison guard at the
penitentiary in Atlanta and guards
testified at the penalty phase that,
uh,
it would be bad for morale if battle was
not given the duck pond good for morale
if he was given the death penalty.
Uh,
should that type
of evidence be admitted,
Megan?
Well,
that gets a little bit trickier because
there are all ready provisions within
our criminal laws that make the severity
of punishment associated with killing a
public officer such as a policeman,
a higher of a,
the penalty is higher than
to kill an ordinary citizen.
Um,
in part because of the criminal justice
system is meant to be the action of the
state against the individual and the
collective against the individual rather
than just the victim
against the defendant.
And so in the,
for me,
the trickiness in that case is because
they're making an appeal to the broader
social or institutional effects of the
crime and they're basically saying this
impedes our ability to carry out a public
service in the same way that the death
of a police officer impedes the ability
of police officers to carry out a public
service.
And so while I would find such,
I mean I'm uncomfortable with
the admission of that testimony.
I think it does push up against this
larger contrast between who exactly is
pursuing the defendant
and the trial and who,
whose justice are we seeking
the victims or the states in a,
in a way that perhaps the,
the more personalized victim
impact statements don't,
they don't,
they don't push up against the
public function of the trial.
In the same way,
the fact that the victim was
a police officer or was a,
a guard at a prison is often
an aggravating circumstance.
So that's already in the mix there.
But then the question becomes,
can members of the police
department members of the,
uh,
the guards a group at the prison,
can they say this will
affect our morale if,
if,
uh,
or,
or you will show your
support for the police?
Uh,
if you give the death polling
in this particular case,
Emma,
I would think not right.
I would think that was
extremely prejudicial.
Um,
and the question that raises for me,
if we're going to admit it,
is why then it wouldn't mean that we're
also admitting testimony from the family
members of the person who's going to be
executed about the potential effects of
the execution on the family.
Cause that's another class of prospective
victims here that we don't talk about
very much.
And that kind of testimony
doesn't come in very much,
but there are cases in which people say,
you know,
you're going to execute my father that
will have long term effects on me.
So should we be letting that and if
we're going to be letting in police
officer's saying,
this will perspectively affect
my morale in a certain way.
What was his defense lawyer to do?
What,
what let's say hypothetically,
what if they're negative,
uh,
characteristics?
Uh,
of the,
let's say the person who
was the victim and the crime was actually
somebody who may have been involved in
illegal activities or may have done
other things that would not reflect
favorably on them.
Is that going to be introduced
as part of this evidence?
Jenny?
So,
so I think that's one of the reasons
that I find victim impact evidence so
problematic is because the 14th amendment
guarantees the right to due process
and a big portion of what our country
believes that due processes is adversarial
testing.
And there's just no way that you can
really attack the credibility of a victim
in this case because the person,
I mean,
the person has died,
they've been the victim of a,
of a horrible
crime.
And so I don't think that if,
if I were a defense lawyer,
I would feel,
um,
that it was extraordinarily risky to
try and attack that kind of evidence.
I think very quickly you're going to look,
um,
petty or like you're playing games or
like you're not respecting the fact that
this is a horrible loss and so,
and it is a horrible loss
and that should be respected.
And so,
um,
I don't think there's any way to
effectively cross examine the testimony.
I don't think,
I don't,
yeah,
I just,
I don't think it can be subjected to
the kind of adversarial testing that we
think is essential to due process.
So if you're the defense lawyer,
you're probably,
even if you know that not going
to put that evidence on right.
Am I right?
Yeah,
that seems like an impossible choice.
I would,
I would think you would always choose no.
Right.
So that was one of the concerns.
Justice Powell had a course
in the booth case was that,
uh,
the really may not be much back and forth
with regard to this kind of evidence.
Well.
Any final thoughts that anyone wants to,
uh,
sure,
sure.
Yeah.
Uh,
you going back to the previous question,
we're talking about crimes happening in
a social context and I often think about
the case being brought against George
Zimmerman about the death of Trayvon
Martin.
And think about the importance of a
victim impact evidence being brought into
that trial as it goes on.
And the need to make sure that the voices
of people who have been affected by
the death of this young
man are going to be heard.
And I think that that's an example
that I think challenges some of our
assumptions about who is the
defendant and who is a victim.
And in this situation,
I think that there is a lot of justice
that can be given to communities,
young people,
uh,
black communities that have been denied
justice for long periods of time by
letting their voice and their,
their experience be part of this trial.
And I think that's an example
where I think we're going to see,
uh,
Vic,
if we see victim impact
evidence abroad into that trial,
I think we're going to see a,
a lot of,
um,
a lot of people who've been denied
justice in the past feel like the America,
the,
the criminal justice system in America
is starting to do them a favor a or work
in their favor I should say.
Um,
and I,
I look forward to seeing the
conversations around that.
Of course,
that's a very high profile case.
What about the day to day case?
I mean,
in cases that we don't hear
about on the national news and,
and,
and there were just what's going on
in communities all across the country.
I think that victim impact evidence
introduces or perhaps exacerbate some
structural disparities that we already
have existing within our criminal justice
system around access to
counsel and competent counsel.
Perhaps counsel notes that the victim
impact evidence will be prejudicial,
but it doesn't raise that
objection in the trial.
And so now we have individuals sentenced
to death because of the quality of
victim impact evidence.
Um,
and that I think is an impermissible
risk and that's something that we worry
about when we are imposing the death
penalty to the extent that the society
continues to do so.
And so,
although I agree with Jamil
on incorporating the views
and perspectives of the
community and ensuring their voice,
the voice of the victims in this process,
I think we have to be very
concerned about how we
are embedding within to the process.
I'm more structural disparities that
we as a society have not decided to
rectify.
Jenny,
would you add anything to that?
Um,
I would just add I agree with Jimmy Earl.
I think his point is well taken,
but I think that we need to be really
careful and remember that in individual
trials we still have an
individual system of adjudication.
Ultimately it's about the individual
who committed the crime allegedly.
And um,
and you know,
what happened around that.
So I think that cultural
context is important,
but I think that we can't allow that to
get it get in the way of the individual
defendant having a fair trial.
Um,
and there might be other contexts where
it's more appropriate to have those
conversations,
which are essential,
but maybe not at the penalty
phase of a capital trial.
Chris,
most people on death row are there
for crimes against white people,
overwhelmingly even in states that have
large African American populations,
Georgia for example,
80% of the people on death
row there for murder.
So of white people.
Uh,
does that,
is that a factor or Emma?
Yeah,
I mean I think,
I think the things we're getting at here
today in Jameel's comments and in these
facts about race are that these
are much broader structural issues,
right?
And there's a desire,
I think in what you're talking about
for a more restorative model of dealing
with a crime and for a more restorative
model of dealing with the history of
racism in the United States.
Right?
We want to have a bigger conversation
about where this country is and it gets
condensed into the penalty
phase of a capital murder trial,
which feels like an odd place to do
justice to pat to the past or to racial
injustice.
Um,
but yeah,
I think if you start
to look at the numbers,
you start to look at jury composition
and people of color being excluded from
juries.
You start to look at the McClaskey study
and the number of people who are being
convicted solely because the aggravating
factor is that they are African
American.
You start to just have
fundamental questions about
whether we're really talking
about a justice system
and if this larger conversation isn't
going on or doesn't come to some
resolution,
which seems like it's been
going on for centuries.
Uh,
what do we do with the individual case,
Megan?
Oh Wow.
Huh.
MMM.
I think that we,
we very much lead a space or some
kind of social recognition of the harm
associated with murder.
Um,
that,
uh,
a lot of what Virginia has been saying
about the deep need for victim's families
to,
to gain public appreciation for their,
for their suffering.
Okay.
But it doesn't fit into
the adversarial trial.
It doesn't,
it's not fair to any individual defendant
to compress all of those wide variety
of issues into the penalty phase.
And so in,
I mean,
in the meantime I suppose my preferred
solution is to exclude most of this
evidence absent maybe some written
statements but also to work on developing
forms of restorative justice
or alternative procedures
that don't determine
whether a person lives or dies,
but nevertheless provide this opportunity
for social recognition of the arm.
The very profound harm that has
happened in any death penalty case.
Well is this discussion is brought out,
this is a credibly a contentious issue
and there is questions about who should
it come in at all,
what's the limit?
We've just touched on
some of those things.
We could talk about him a lot longer.
Uh,
but uh,
this is how long we'll
talk about them today.
I want to thank everyone for coming and
being a part of this discussion and I
hope that it's helpful as we
think through this question,
uh,
because eventually the supreme court
probably will look at this question again
and decide some of these things we've
talked about particularly about the scope,
uh,
or that by that I mean what
evidence is going to be admitted.
Uh,
how extensive,
it can be characterizations the sort of
opinions like in the battle case that we
discussed.
So thank you all very much,
uh,
most grateful to you for your
contributions to our discussion.